wendy is a
former matlab user he even wrote a book
about matlab
then turned open source so let's all
give a big round of applause to wendy
for coming to the open source side
everyone please welcome wendy to the
stage thank you for that uh
wonderful introduction um and thank you
for
uh you know inviting me to be here today
uh
and i'm really happy to be able to uh
share a journey that i've been on
uh with our as as my companion
so uh any journey i think has to have a
destination
and the destination part on your screen
and see where it says stop sharing and
hide could you click hide so everyone
can see all your slides
oh hi like that
you're welcome i wasn't sure if i was
hearing things because i just heard this
little voice
on your shoulder
anyway thank you all right
so um so here's uh my destination
essentially is to uh get our approved
for production so we could use it for
production purposes
at the bureau of labor statistics so in
terms of this talk i'm going to talk a
little bit more about who i
am uh and what is a federal statistical
agency
because i think that sets some context
for uh
this journey or this road that i'm on
and then i'll talk about some of the
the rocks and the obstacles that i've
encountered along the way
and uh let you know where i am now
because i'm not quite at my destination
yet
so a little bit about my uh education um
i got
a uh my bachelor's degree i had a double
major
in math and physics from a small liberal
arts
school in lawton oklahoma from there i
i got a research fellowship at um
it's kind of a offshoot off-campus
school part of the george washington
university
uh but it was at nasa langley research
center
and i got my master's in in engineering
from there i i went to work at the naval
surface warfare center
uh in in dahlgren virginia and they
supported my
phd work at george mason university
where i got my phd
in computational sciences and
informatics with an emphasis
on computational statistics uh and
about eight years ago i moved to the
bureau of labor statistics
and a condition of getting the job was
that i had to take some courses
on how to work with data from a complex
sample design
so i ended up going back to school
as a much older student which of course
was pretty challenging
so i said i worked for the naval surface
warfare center i there i did
um basic and applied research in support
of the marine corps
from there i went to the office of naval
research
and that's a funding agency sort of
similar to the
national science foundation but there
there was a lot of fun i wasn't able to
do
you know research or analysis or
anything but
instead i came up with the research
ideas and i gave money to people to
to have the fun of doing it after a
while i went to
what i call a dark agency still in the
department of defense
uh where i had the opportunity then to
re-engage with
analyzing data and then as i said about
eight years ago
i left defense and came to the ls
so here's uh where bls is located this
is our building it's called the postal
square building
uh right now i'm coming to you talking
to you from my home
because we're a full-time telework but
once we get back
uh this is where i'll be and it's right
across from union station
uh and it's actually part of the
smithsonian
that door that you see right there is a
i guess if you can see my cursor
that's the entrance to the postal museum
so
if you can get there it's a great place
to visit
so some of you may not know much about
uh
the statistical agencies and wasn't
until of course i
came to bls that i really even knew that
they existed i'm
ashamed to say but um anyway there's 13
of them one of them is bls
and you can see from this list that they
span a lot of uh areas so from
economics labor crime transportation
demographics uh education
uh agriculture and a lot more
now the reason why this is important and
why it impacts this road that i'm
on is because each of these agencies are
responsible for producing
very important official statistics these
statistics are used by
the public by decision makers lawmakers
uh
you know really everybody and so here's
just an example
of of some of the ones that at least the
bls
does and one that you probably are
familiar with which is the monthly
employment situation uh that those are
produced by the
bls and also the consumer price index
so the reason why this is important uh
is because
by law we have to produce and publish
these statistics
and the production of these statistics
relies on
our it infrastructure as well as the
software that we use
to produce them so we can't just go to
the public and say oh i'm sorry
we can't we can't give you the
employment situation this month
because uh you know our software failed
or we had some
some glitch so we have to be very very
careful
now a former commissioner of bls erica
dr erica groshan
kind of coined this created this acronym
which i think is
well really it's at the heart of what we
do
and how we produce data and the
statistics
that has to be accurate objective
relevant
timely and accessible again the software
that we use
to produce our statistics that we need
to
account for all of these important
priorities
so what about this rocky road that i'm
on well i mentioned my destination which
was to get
our approved for production at the ls
but what was the start of my journey
well i was first exposed to r in uh when
i was working on my phd
and when i was working on these slides i
was trying to think if this was
if i really had used r back then and i'm
pretty sure that i did because
this was in the early 90s and around
that time you know s
plus was around so i know i used s plus
but
but there was also r there and during my
time at
at the office of naval research i didn't
have a chance to really
do uh much research so you know i didn't
use
r but then once i got back to when i
got back into analysis and i was at this
dark agency
i was sort of you know jumping in at the
deep end of the pool so to speak
so you might suspect that uh you know
agency like this that we had there were
classified networks
and so we couldn't just you know go to
crean because these networks weren't
connected to the outside world
so you couldn't just go to cran and you
know install our packages
but one of the statisticians there what
he did was
like twice a year he would go to crayon
and essentially download everything off
of cran
uh and get it checked out make sure it
was okay they would install it on the
network so essentially
on our networks we had uh cran mirrors
where we could
uh you know install packages and our and
use it
the other thing i did when i was at this
agency was i um
developed a two-day intro to our course
uh and i'm not quite sure why i did it
but anyway i did it and taught it
several times there
and it was you know people liked it the
other thing
that i came to appreciate was that they
would set up these communities of
practice
so these would be groups of you know
colleagues that would come together and
talk
you know they'd have this common
interest and you know they would help
each other out
so i kind of took those ideas uh with me
to bls
uh and i kind of revised the course and
taught it
i've been teaching it at bls probably
two or three times a year and i think
it's
you know probably the the most popular
course uh
there and the other thing i did was uh
i started uh our interest at our users
group
uh at the agency and i have to say i
didn't
ask permission to do that i just kind of
did it
and it's been fairly it's been very
successful
and it's still going very strong the
other thing that's important
uh you know about this journey that i'm
on is the fact that sas u i mean bls
uses sas
uh not totally but but it uses it in
particular for the the employment
situation to get those numbers out
and many of the statistical agencies are
you know use sas
now you could as you might expect you
know this is government
we can't just you know install whatever
we want on our computers
and i have to say that that bls is
pretty open
uh to us you know installing things on
our computers as long as we ask for
permission and they go through this kind
of a security check and an approval
process
but the approval distinguishes between
whether the software is going to be used
for research
or production and so one of the problems
has been what does it mean to be
production software
and nobody really had a good definition
of that it's pretty vague
but essentially in my opinion it would
be whatever software
you use to produce uh an effect you know
official statistics
so here's a graphic that kind of shows
the um
approval history uh for r and the green
is the uh so this starts from 2015 to
the current time and uh the the green
means it was approved for production and
the blue means it's approved for
research
so you might be saying to yourself well
wendy what what's going on you've
already
reached your destination you know it's
been approved for production
well as you can see it's not right now
and what's happened along the way is
that
it gets approved for production i'm all
excited about it and then
somebody says oh wait a minute you know
we can't we can't have that
and so then it gets uh
kind of kicked back to being for
research purposes only
so i'm still not at my destination
now my colleague brandon cobb developed
this graphic as well as the previous one
to show kind of what's the status of
software at bls
for production use and and research and
then by
um you know what's the the
software used for and this first column
so the production is on across the top
in green
uh and if you look under the languages
that are approved for production you
have python
and uh if you look all the way to the
right under the other
block you see anaconda and qgis
those of course are all open source
uh and one of the issues or comments
we've had about
why ours not approved for production
it's well
uh you know we need to be able to just
call somebody up if we have a problem
uh that's why we like to have commercial
software
uh you know commercially supported
software so but
you know here we have examples where
uh open source is used
for production so why use
r well this is predominantly in our
conference i'm sure we all
you'll love r uh and we know
why we want to use it but you hear some
of the things that that we've tried to
use as a as a selling point
um i think you know the fact that
uh functionality or you know new new
research is is often implemented in r
uh and then it doesn't become available
in commercial software
for a long time if ever uh when we hire
um
people right out of our school they
usually know r
or python but uh they don't know sas you
have to
have to train them and i think
there's this opportunity for innovation
when we when we use
are and i'm going to give you just a
couple of quick examples
so there's a survey we have called the
occupational employment statistics
survey
it publishes annually um
statistics on employment and wages for
over
800 occupations and i think various
industries
and for different geographic levels
now the um the maps that they produce
i'm going to show you they're
they're static and they're they're
produced in using sas
so here's an example of the the user
interface
uh you have these drop down menus and
you could select the occupation
and then what statistic you want and
essentially what it does what they do
is they use sas to create a map
for every combination of statistic
and occupation and so on and so then
these are just kept on a server
somewhere
and essentially these um
these interfaces these drop down menus
are just used to access what file it is
on the server so it's really not dynamic
at all
uh and then in 2015 and i thought to
myself well this would be
a really i mean we could create a shiny
app
that would kind of do or create a
version of that
that would be truly dynamic so that's
what we did
uh we had two economists so these
weren't even
you know statisticians or pro computer
programmers
so they had little to no r experience
and
almost zero shiny our shiny experience
and uh we asked them to do this but the
thing is that they knew the data
uh and so just for two days a week and i
think
within two months they had uh an app
built
that uh would kind of do this
dynamically so here's some screenshots
uh you know the legend would change and
the title
and you could change i think color and
and there's you could hover over the
areas and get information
the other thing is they would it would
also create this table based on the
the data that you had displayed in the
map
and you could then download the data
to use to use yourself
another uh brandon cop actually did this
one too
he created this app for our publications
department
they wanted to sort of automatically
generate text that could be used in on
new statements because
you know a lot of times it's it's not
necessarily boilerplate but it could be
somewhat similar and then you would just
uh you know kind of put the right
numbers in there
so in order to demonstrate you know what
he could do what he was doing he said
well let me just put this in
our shiny app and you know he could
show it to stakeholders so they could
see uh what are the possibilities
so the point about these examples is the
fact that
they these weren't created by our it
people
they were created by the uh
the subject domain experts
uh and that's kind of where i think
innovation happens
now i love this sign because this really
i think illustrates
what i feel my road has been like these
past uh several years
so just some of the issues that we've
encountered
uh first of all one is that people do
still want to use r for research so they
want to be able to just
you know install whatever packages they
want whereas on the production
side they say well you know we have to
have more control over the
versions and so forth there's also this
idea of sas versus r when i started this
i think the
people thought especially in the i.t
department thought
if we get r approved for production that
means
we're saying we're getting rid of sas
and we have to convert everything that's
in sas to r
and nobody's ever said that because that
would be a huge
undertaking right remember our monthly
employment numbers
they have to go out uh and you know
nobody's saying that
we're just saying where it makes sense
to use are let us do it
uh and then the other one
the other sort of pushback that we often
get is well
you have people in the you know the
subject domain experts developing the
our shiny apps
what happens when they leave you know
how you don't
what are you going to do with the you
know updates or fixing it or whatever at
that point
well you have that same problem with you
know the
the java programmers in the it
department so there's
got to be ways that that we could you
know kind of mitigate that risk
so what happened about um oh gosh i
don't even know how long ago now but
maybe like two or three years ago
i was ready to get r approved for
production the executives said no
we just need to go back and do a process
to approve
software in general for production so we
did that and presented it to the
executives a year ago
and uh they just
you know massive pushback uh and they
said
all right so at that point i was kind of
ready to just quit
but uh somebody our deputy commissioner
said well no let's just get a smaller
team
we'll take this process that you
developed and uh fill it out for r
so we did that uh and that was a good
that was a good um exercise because we
kind of revised the process
and then instead of um going back to the
executives and saying okay give us the
approval we said
well let's just have a little smaller
approval team that has the authority to
approve it
and see what they think of our our
application
so it's in their hands right now we're
trying to
we want a quick turnaround we don't want
this team to be
taking six months to give us an answer
so we're hoping to have
an answer in uh well about a month so
we'll see what happens
so what have i learned in this process
uh well one of them is just be patient
you know keep trying uh i think as we've
gone on one of the
one of the folks in the it department
where
you know five years ago he was sort of
pushed back with us he's now completely
on board and very supportive
and so i think you just have to you kind
of plant a lot of seeds
and uh you know nurture them and and
you'll get there
so i'm i'm hopeful uh and i just want to
finish with a plug or
you know an advertisement that several
years ago i started an interagency r
users group
uh and we're just kind of
informal uh and if you're interested in
uh you know are used in the government
then just
send me an email and i could add you uh
to our list
great it definitely seems like a bumpy
road and that's something i've seen at
many many federal agencies too
and some move at different paces depends
you know what their mission is and who's
there so
thank you for fighting the good fight
for r especially someone that used to be
a matlab user
and coming over to the open source it's
really amazing to hear